jack dorsey square block and cash app
they're going all in on bitcoin that's
no secret but today cash app has
announced that they are going to start
integrating lightning network yes the
layer two of bitcoin is now going to be
available to anyone on the cash app in
the united states what this means is
that you as a cash app user are going to
be able to send bitcoin completely for
free instantaneously to anyone in the
world that's also plugged into the
lightning network the reason why this is
important is because previously tons of
financial applications things that allow
you to send payments to your friends to
your family or to strangers they only
work compatible with other users of that
app you want to use paypal the other
person has to have paypal you want to
use cash app somebody else has to have
cash app you couldn't send something
from venmo to cash app you couldn't send
something from cash app to paypal
everything was a closed garden but now
all of a sudden when cash app goes ahead
and integrates the lightning network it
doesn't matter what app you have as long
as it's integrated with the lightning
network it is compatible and so a strike
user can send money to a cash app user a
cash app user can send someone to a moon
wallet any wallet any financial service
any bank it doesn't matter where you
actually get into the network as long as
that network is supported then you now
can go ahead and transact with each
other this is a massive deal not only
because it allows for interoperability
between these apps these banks and these
various types of assets but also because
what it does is it allows for free
instantaneous transactions of bitcoin to
anyone in the world anytime without
asking for permission imagine the
economic impact that now people can send
money to their friends their family or
to other people that they're doing
business with and they can do it without
asking permission and they do it for
free when you reduce friction for
sending money globally it leads to more
human productivity it leads to a boom in
economic prosperity and so right out of
the cash app press release what you can
see is they say rolling out in the
coming weeks cash app customers in the
united states will be able to use the
lightning network to send bitcoin for
free to anyone anywhere in the world
within seconds customers can send
bitcoin internationally from cash app to
any external compatible wallet to a
friend family members a self-managed
wallet or any merchant that accepts
lightning network payments with zero
fees this is an absolute game changer
jack dorsey square block and the cash
app team they're not gonna get enough
credit for this but this is one more
step in a milestone on the way marching
towards global adoption bitcoin is
inevitable and cash app is proving it
with this lightning network integration
they won't be the last one to do it of
the major payment platforms